.
>> Bret: YOU GOT IT.
♪
>> WE ALL REMEMBER NOVEMBER OF
2008, IT WASN'T THE BEST OF
TIMES.
DEMOCRATS WON EVERYTHING.
THE MESSIAH WON THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND THE SENATE AND CONGRESS WAS
BLUE AS MONICA'S DRESS.
BUT TWO YEARS LATER WE HAD A TEA
PARTY.
[CHANTING WE THE PEOPLE]
[CHANTING U.S.A.]
[TYRANNY NEVER, FREEDOM FOREVER]
>> Jesse: EVERYBODY SAW THAT
WAVE COMING, WELL, EVERYBODY
EXCEPT JOE BIDEN.
>> TO QUOTE A MISSOURIAN, SAMUEL
CLEMMONS WHO SAID AND I WILL
PARAPHRASE HIM, RELATING TO OUR
PARTY, THE REPORTS OF THE DEATH
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAVE
BEEN GREATLY EXAGGERATED.
GREATLY EXAGGERATED.
[APPLAUSE]
AND IT'S BECAUSE OF YOU GUYS.
IT'S BECAUSE OF YOU GUYS.
I'M HERE TO TELL YOU THAT ON
NOVEMBER THE 3RD, ON NOVEMBER
THE 3RD, THE DAY AFTER THE --
THIS COMING ELECTION, THERE WILL
BE IN WASHINGTON, D.C. A
DEMOCRATIC MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE
AND A DEMOCRATIC MAJORITY IN THE
SENATE.
[CHEERS]
>> THAT WILL BE THE CASE.
AND WERE IT NOT ILLEGAL I WOULD
MAKE BOOK ON IT.
>> Jesse: THE BIG GUY WOULD HAVE
LOST BANK.
THAT'S WHY HUNTER RUNS THE
FAMILY FINANCES.
DEMOCRATS GOT SHE LACKED, THEY
LOST 63 HOUSE SEATS AND SIX
SENATE SEATS AND THEN OCCUPY
WALL STREET LAUNCHED AND THEY
ASKED BARACK, CAN YOU PLEASE AT
LEAST PUT ONE BANKER IN PRISON?
BARRY DIDN'T.
INSTEAD OF BEING PRO-WORKER,
DEMOCRATS GOT INTO PRONOUNS AND
NOW, 12 YEARS LATER, AS OBAMA'S
PASTOR FAMOUSLY SAID THE
CHICKENS ARE COMING HOME TO
ROOST.
>> AN ECONOMY THAT'S VERY GOOD
FOR FOLKS AT THE VERY TOP BUT
NOT ALWAYS SO GOOD FOR ORDINARY
PEOPLE.
COMMUNITIES WHERE TOO MANY
KIDS -- ARE YOU GOING TO START
YELLING?
[SHOUTING]
WHY DO YOU START YELLING?
[BOOS]
>> HOLD ON, EVERYBODY, DON'T GET
DISTRACTED.
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
HOLD UP, HOLD UP.
HOLD UP.
YOU HAVE TO BE POLITE AND CIVIL
WHEN PEOPLE ARE TALKING THAT
OTHER PEOPLE ARE TALKING.
>> Jesse: YES, WE CAN CAMPAIGN
FOR A LADY WHO HELD MOCK SLAVE
AUCTIONS IN HIGH SCHOOL.
AND AOC'S BASE IS FURIOUS
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO MAKE LOVE, NOT WAR.
>> YOU VOTED TO SEND ARMS AND
WEAPONS TO UKRAINE.
YOU RAN AS AN OUTSIDER.
YET, YOU HAVE BEEN VOTING TO
START THIS WAR IN UKRAINE.
YOU ARE VOTING TO START A
NUCLEAR WAR WITH RUSSIA AND
CHINA.
WHY ARE YOU PLAYING WITH THE
LIVES OF AMERICAN CITIZENS?
>> YOU HAVE DONE NOTHING!
I BELIEVED IN YOU, AND YOU
BECAME THE VERY THING YOU SOUGHT
TO FIGHT AGAINST.
>> Jesse: YOU CAN FEEL IT
EVERYWHERE.
IF I TOLD YOU THAT THE "THE
WASHINGTON POST" A WEEK BEFORE
THE MIDTERMS RAN A COLUMN
ENTITLED FOR THE GOOD OF THE
COUNTRY BIDEN AND HARRIS SHOULD
BOW OUT, YOU WOULD SAY WATTERS,
YOU ARE SMOKING TOAD FIN NUMB
BUT I'M SOBERLY TOBER.
DEMOCRATS ARE TWISTING AND
TURNING ON IMMIGRATION.
THINGS ARE GETTING SO BAD GAVIN
NEWSOM STARTED TELLING THE
TRUTH.
>> DOES IT FEEL LIKE A RED WAVE?
>> YEAH, OF COURSE IT DOES.
AND AGAIN, I'M NOT PAID TO SAY
THAT I'M PAID TO SAY, YOU KNOW,
I GET IT.
LOOK, I CAN BE THE CHEERLEADER,
I'M ALSO A PRAGMATIST.
I FEEL IT.
>> Jesse: THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
THAT NEWSOM FELT ANYTHING THAT
IS NOT NARCISSISM.
IS HE EMOTIONALLY DEVELOPING AND
WE ARE VERY PROUD OF HIM.
ONE DAY HE WILL FEEL EMPATHY,
TOO.
DEMOCRAT KEEP TELLING US A CIVIL
WAR IS COMING AND THEY ARE
RIGHT.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE THE CIVIL
WAR BETWEEN REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS.
IT'S GOING TO BE A DEMOCRAT
CIVIL WAR.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE ABOUT TO START
BLAMING EACH OTHER AND AS USUAL,
THE MEDIA IS GOING TO START
BLAMING YOU, THE VOTERS.
>> I READ A POLL JUST YESTERDAY
THAT WHITE REPUBLICAN SUBURBAN
WOMEN ARE NOW GOING TO VOTE
REPUBLICAN.
>> WHY?
>> IT'S ALMOST LIKE ROACHES
VOTING FOR RAID.
>> Jesse: AS SOMEONE WHO KNOWS
WHITE SUBURBAN WOMEN THAN
ANYBODY THE LADIES PULLING UP TO
POTTERY BARN JEEP GRAND
CHEROKEES WON'T LIKE THAT.
BILL CLINTON SAYS REPUBLICANS
ARE TOYING WITH YOUR EMOTIONS.
>> THE REPUBLICANS ARE PRETTY
SIMPLE, ACTUALLY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> AND PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD.
THEY SAY I WANT YOU TO BE VERY
MISERABLE.
[LAUGHTER]
AND I WANT YOU TO BE VERY ANGRY.
AND I WANT YOU TO VOTE FOR US
AND WE'LL MAKE IT WORSE BUT WE
WILL BLAME THEM.
>> Jesse: I THOUGHT BILL CLINTON
WAS SUPPOSED TO FEEL YOUR PAIN.
WHAT ELSE IS HE FEELING?
DEFINITELY NOT HILLARY.
YEAH.
WE ARE NOT SCARED OF BEING
PUSHED ON THE SUBWAY, RAPED OR
SHOT.
WE ARE SCARED BECAUSE
REPUBLICANS ARE POUNCING.
>> ADS ABOUT CRIME EVERY 30
SECONDS, RIGHT?
NO SOLUTIONS, BUT, JUST A LOT OF
REALLY FEARFUL, SCARY PICTURES
AND SCARY MUSIC.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT KEEPING
YOU SAFE.
THEY WANT TO KEEP YOU SCARED.
>> Jesse: IF THINGS ARE SO
GREAT, WHY AREN'T THESE HEAVY
HITTERS GOING TO SWING STATES?
BIDEN JUST CAME BACK FROM
CAMPAIGNING IN OREGON.
LAST NIGHT HE GAVE THE CAMPAIGN
SPEECH IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
AND TODAY JOBE IS CAMPAIGNING IN
CALIFORNIA.
KAMALA WAS CAMPAIGNING IN THE
FAMOUS SWING STATE OF
MASSACHUSETTS YESTERDAY.
THE THIRD TIME SHE HAS BEEN TO
MASSACHUSETTS SINCE AUGUST.
STILL HASN'T BEEN TO THE BORDER.
TODAY THE DEMOCRATS ASSEMBLED AN
ALL-FEMALE DREAM TEAM, HILLARY,
KAMALA, LETITIA JAMES.
THEY ARE CAMPAIGNING IN ON
BEHALF OF KATHY HOCHUL RUNNING
FOR GOVERNOR.
A REPUBLICAN MIGHT WIN THE
GOVERNOR'S MANSION IN NEW YORK
SO THEY'RE BRINGING OUT THE BIG
GUNS.
SHE IS AT RISK OF LOSING THE
SEAT IN NEW YORK NOW DEMOCRATS
ARE ON DEFENSE.
CROOKED IS THERE, KAMALA.
I MEAN, COME ON, TALKING ABOUT
LINING UP ON YOUR OWN ONE YARD
LINE, NEW YORK IS A WAR ZONE.
JUST THIS MORNING A WOMAN OUT
JOGGING IN THE WEST VILLAGE BY
THE HUDSON RIVER NICE PLACE GOT
RAPED.
>> THE NYPD SAYS A 43-YEAR-OLD
FEMALE WAS JOGGING NEAR PIER 45
WHEN SHE WAS SEXUALLY ASSAULTED
5:30.
AUTHORITIES SAY THE MAIL SUSPECT
APPROACHED THE VICTIM FROM
BEHIND, CHOKED HER AND ASSAULTED
HER.
HE ROBBED THE VICTIM STEALING
HER CELL PHONE AND CREDIT CARDS
BEFORE TAKING OFF.
THE PARAMEDICS TOOK THE VICTIM
TO A LOCAL HOSPITAL FOR
TREATMENT OF HER INJURIES.
THURSDAY AFTERNOON THE NYPD SAYS
THEY TOOK A PERSON INTO CUSTODY.
>> Jesse: YEAH, THE PERSON IN
CUSTODY, HE'S HOMELESS AND HAS
GOT 18 ARRESTS ON HIS RECORD.
IN BUFFALO, NEW YORK, THE GUY
BEAT THE HELL OUT OF HIS WIFE.
LOOK AT THIS.
LOOK AT THOSE PUNCHES.
AND THEN HE WAS LET OUT WITH NO
BAIL.
KNOW WHAT I DID NEXT?
HE MURDERED HER.
DEMOCRAT KATHY HOCHUL WAS
CORNERED YESTERDAY ON THIS AND
SHE BLAMED THE SYSTEM.
>> WILL THE SUSPECTED ACTUALLY
FAILED HER.
THE SYSTEM HAS TO WORK.
ORDERS OF PROTECTION HAVE TO BE
GRANTED.
TRANSITION HOMES HAVE TO BE
AVAILABLE AND WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT JUDGES AND PROSECUTORS
CHARGE APPROPRIATELY.
>> Jesse: SHE IS THE SYSTEM.
AND HER MESSAGE IS THE SYSTEM
KILLED THIS WOMAN SO REELECTED
THE SYSTEM ON TUESDAY.
KAMALA HARRIS JUST WRAPPED UP
HER SPEECH AT THIS HILLARY
HOCHUL EVENT AND VICE PRESIDENT
DIDN'T EVEN MENTION CRIME.
WOMEN ARE GETTING RAPED AND
MURDERED EVERY DAY AND THE MOST
POWERFUL WOMEN IN THE WORLD
IGNORE IT.
THAT